Chinese stock prices are rebounding with
the country's Blue Chip company staging
their biggest rally since 2022 Chinese
technology company Alibaba was among the
biggest gainers it comes days after
Chinese stock market valuations fell to
5year lows last week behind the
turnaround government intervention
China's Securities regulator vowed to
take steps to crack down on what it
described as malicious Short Selling and
urged institutional investors to expand
their investment ments some hedge funds
and brokerages reported bans on selling
and a state fund dubbed the national
team also intervened helping to stem a
selloff but analysts say unless more is
done to stimulate China's stagnating
economic growth government efforts could
backfire the expectation is so weak um
and that means even if temporarily uh
maybe the state can do something to uh
push the stock market up um but that
would cause more people to sell rather
than to buy so in the short term
actually we have this high risk that a
chinaese stock market will go down much
further China's growth achieved last
year's government Target of 5% but the
international monetary fund predicts
more problems to come for the world's
second largest economy the property
sector a major driver of growth is in
Decline with no sign of
recovery China's volatile stock market
is just one symptom of a widespread
confidence crisis the government has so
far refused to implement any major
effort to stimulate the economy and many
experts believe that until that happens
gains will be shortlived and pessimism
about the country's future will remain
Katrina U alaz
Beijing make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aler